when six is right now putting on a show  of dominance start to this third quarter  it's the largest lead of the game  there's James goes across the line lays  it up and lays it in and there it is he  just became the third leading scorer in  NBA history passing Kobe Bryant another  milestone for the greats LeBron James  and the Laker fans well aware of it oh  absolutely  Bible can't hit James the rebound all  its left ahead of him this Kareem  abdul-jabbar and Karl Malone nice feed  inside James to Davis back-to-back  buckets as Brett Brown call a quick  timeout in his 17th season LeBron James  last Jerry pass Michael Jordan  put it on the big screen here the Wells  Fargo Center and everybody in the  building  giving LeBron James a standing ovation  [Applause]  [Music]